[Music]
in refrigerating news nope that is oh
refer to what refrigerant dating news
that is a ridiculous were dating mm-hmm
submitted by save the cat Oh
Samsung wants to turn your refrigerator
into tinder why oh maybe it's it's like
okay I'm not gonna eat something shitty
cuz I could see my dating app right here
look better right you'll be more fit so
you choose the healthier food exactly
because they have though it's like like
a big ice screen right like you can draw
on it you could yeah it's called the
Samsung family hub refrigerator which is
a $4,000 refrigerator with the touch
screen on the door and then you could
use that to see like your calendar and
then it also has this feature where it
could take a photo of the inside of your
refrigerator so you can know what you
have in stock so like when you're
shopping for groceries or whatever you
can watch movies yeah you can watch
movies you can stream stuff wow that's
crazy actually
well what if I just open the fridge I
took a picture so I remember I go
supermarket how many times have you done
that exactly yeah exactly
no that's like let's say you forgot to
do that before you left well you're at
the grocery store you could see like a
live whoa that's dope yeah but if you
before that's not fridge you just call
your [ __ ] wife or your husband or
somebody
oh yeah Butler yeah your Butler exactly
like you you're obviously doing well
you're probably married you two in come
home like $4,000 for a refrigerator
that's what I'm saying how much does a
refrigerator cost like normally the one
with the ice in the water that you
should know I should know because they
meet a new fridge so if I need a new
fridge super shot when starting out like
400 bucks 500 bucks the one with the ice
and the water no we need that I snore
I need the ice in the water that's a
thousand bucks like minimum okay no it
is a thousand about it that with the ice
in the water I know I've been in the
market right now currently I am what
happen whether were supposed to go
refrigerator we're gonna go together
okay yeah sure a term art that I don't
know about where you go we're gonna Best
Buy usually go to Home Depot so you can
go to Best Buy I think Home Depot too
and you can price match [ __ ] the fine on
Amazon elsewhere this is some old people
[ __ ] can we talk about [ __ ] young
stuff oh yeah what do you got what do
you got your young ma what do we got I
just want to know where the tinder comes
in the prodigal let's talk about tinder
yeah all right so there's this free app
this dating app it's called refrigerator
got what it was like looking for [ __ ]
it's not in your fridge that's how you
know we're all that's true I never even
[ __ ] doesn't even get my radar I
never look for [ __ ] either you've been
out of the game the longest time yeah
very long how long two thousand eleven
years holy [ __ ] wait before me that you
weren't even dating so it's been longer
than that I was dating before you oh my
bad
you Dan
dude was horrible [ __ ] and it was right
in front of his face but then he wasn't
even taking it is what was happening I
was not friendzone - she would give me
all this advice that would make me look
like a creep in front of all these lives
yes really
whoa who the bar whisperer
yes so you got him cock-blocked whoa did
no don't even say it like that okay this
is what happened he has zero idea how
are you so defense this is going what's
going cut is no I want to know the thing
on this now Bart I'm sorry
so Bart has a zero game like zero me
that's how he got you like in the
negative
I made the first move thank you because
he has the rope game and then he would
just ask me like hey I want my my bond
date with this chick or whatever I'm
thinking about making her like a like a
CD with like different like house music
or whatever and then we're just gonna
drive down the beach put the windows
down just listen to music and then like
we'll just hang out share music yeah I
was a good idea sounds cool [ __ ]
creep why am I in this cause it was full
CD so I don't know he was just so I was
like dude that sounds cool like that
sounds chill like we get to talk it's
like it's just honest like that oh that
would be cool uh and then he said that
he had the windows down and she just had
a hoodie on and she died pulled it like
that I forgot is I'm a hot person so I
think what was my norm was probably
freezing for her you know you know
looking like we're doing this the whole
day you think the game's working yet
yeah who sabotage you like it was this
young you saved this man you poor you
pulled him out of a [ __ ] ocean he was
drowning right I'm going to heaven now
I've done the good deed yeah you have
thank you
hey whatever it takes no he didn't need
it apparently I made up a fake story to
make this whole CD to finally get you it
took three years of me dating his friend
and then us breaking up and then he made
the kill
that's how much game he has just chill
and she's gonna want me one day yep
and it works yeah I used to watch her
every day
yes braces he had fucked-up vision so he
would text like this so aren't you
proving my game or if you have great
games you're proving my god yes got a
great game wow this game is so good that
you can't even see that he's pulling
strings from behind the scenes who is a
mastermind he's part of this big taste
tastes like boba
[Laughter]
we're spit brothers know we're dick
brothers dick knows that Eskimo ask
Eskimo brothers yes we [ __ ] the same
person critical Channel anyway we're
talking about refriger dating so this is
what the app looks like
so samsung says it the way it works
really cool though they got nothing but
green products it takes a photo of the
inside of your refrigerator and then you
use it on this app like to upload your
refrigerator Valley and then you kind of
like you swipe through refrigerators
that's how it works
like tinder oh you see other people oh
hell no see other people yeah you get to
know like what kind of person what if
there's body parts in one of them is
creepy guys we're really dirty
refrigerator yeah exactly you are gonna
thank you so much about a person like
like how clean they are because if
there's like that juice left on the
[ __ ] layer like a bottom yeah people
are gonna start donating to me and
starting a Kickstarter because they're
gonna think I'm very poor empty yeah we
got like put two waters in one egg a
[ __ ] pack of baloney and [ __ ] don't
you guys cook all the time in there
that's why oh because we always because
there's so many markets close to us I
don't stock anything anymore yeah that's
awesome I know what a time waster I know
there's like 70% of stuff is gone all
right we gotta go shop every time you
cook that's pretty cool though cuz the
shopping doesn't take an hour it's gonna
be like 15 minutes no cuz I cook now so
I know these things Wow
and the thing is a lot of people they'll
stock the fridge and then don't have to
throw away like 50% of their stuff
because they don't use it dude that's me
and [ __ ] lettuce and loss [ __ ] Nikki
buys the mic man we don't use this [ __ ]
ever yeah but it forces you if you're
you know to use everything before you go
and buy more stuff yeah absolutely why
should I let us all the time
she buys is just like more of it than
she needs but then I am I have a good
because I buy more of everything than I
need so it's
because it's on sale you're goddamn
right cuz I get the [ __ ] deal [ __ ]
deal yeah absolutely coop pop cake but
then Nicky usually just get some like
lettuce and then wilts in like a day and
a half I swear to God and then we end up
ordering Thai food in the crisper
crispers bunch of [ __ ] we have one
drawer where I've bok choy in there for
like three months is still good really
remember that box I was cutting now yeah
I was looking at it I'm like that shit's
questionable I wash the block off of it
yeah oh that's good oh good do you live
alone I know I'm a roommate we have a
very empty fridge I eat out a lot or
ordering a lot yeah that's bad I also
drink a lot of Soylent though you guys
into Soylent well no I just wanna diet
what's Soylent it's a meal replacement
you could survive all the sustenance you
nearly twenty percent of every single
vitamin nutrient that you need for the
day within one guy into Soylent it's
just convenient honestly don't have time
to eat you just chug that food like I
just want what does it taste like
there's a bunch of different flavors
eggs oh you can check it out no yeah I
like chocolate there's vanilla chocolate
or like no it's like it's like yeah it's
like a chocolate milkshake or it
milkshakes are centers protein shake so
that's like you can feel it you need to
market it better because Soylent does
not sound like something I'm like oh I
want to easily eat a whole movie called
Soylent Green where it's it's made out
of people dude does it taste good then
why here so and I think like it's made
out of a human's
they wouldn't sell it for that she is it
green - no no it's not bad it's maybe
like you can buy him a 7-eleven for
maybe two and a half dollars 11 yeah I
remember there was a person who like did
an experiment and survived off I'm gonna
do that 30 day challenge
I don't know why does it say your
appetite mmm did you get what you need
but do you feel food I mean I didn't
maybe like one day because I had a uber
driver that he was on Soylent and that's
all he ever took he told me he lost a
bunch of weight on it I'm still fat that
chewing you know what I mean I love
doing that I considered it okay wait
what chewing I really do give me the
exerciser
jamas you have to start chewing double
the gum there's gonna be no because I
chewed so much gum in high school so you
would think that of Steel but it would
just get more fatigue
I think that my body works in Reverse I
don't know it just doesn't work you
can't just make up stuff like that I did
enough exercise when I was like six
years old I did a lot of type of Jamie
don't need it man it's true I didn't
work for me I did a lot of it don't eat
it
that's why don't exercise now because
you did a lot of jungle gym in those
think about the fridge and you know how
people on tinder have the best pictures
like a fake like lives or like oh this
is like me at the beach even though you
don't go to the beach I would wonder if
people would have like fake stalks
pretty why right yeah oh I told you all
these veggies so on the website they do
have some tips for how to do this
refriger dating thing and the number one
thing that they say is like don't fake
it like don't okay oh helping yourself
if you're really trying to and there's
gonna be all this like I'm depressed
fridge videos there's gonna be like guys
you guys don't know how it's [ __ ]
it's like [ __ ] it's so hard for me if
I can adjust it all the time and it
wasn't just that - it was like don't
only try to pick refrigerators that look
exactly like yours because you don't
want to date someone it's exactly like
you you want to do other people like
different people right you want to see
who how do you be the snarky person
who's above it all because you know
there's always people on dating profiles
like yeah so I guess we're supposed to
write something witty here I go you know
how do you do that with like fridge you
know they like put some onion dip or
something like keeps like just fill it
full onion dippers on the house
there's gotta be so many puns you can
make with all the food how do you
deliver upon if it's just visual how
much just have dildos in there that's
pretty good people know you love to [ __ ]
at least I just want to shock somebody
dildo
he called dildos to have called open for
him dildo sickles you can have his and
her dildos yeah looks smart yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]